so on the bound for the padres today is
joe musgrove it's so fitting that the
local kid joe musgrove is uh pitching
the last home game of the 2021 campaign
there are his numbers up to this point
of the season here at petco park he's
got a fine era of 3.54 28 year old one
ball no strikes
freddie
to shallow center that's going to drop
in front of grisham back-to-back hits
for atlanta
everything going right for the braves
who are riding that wave of a 10-8 win
last night
good start all beasts coming up
on the ground right side frazier will go
to second for one on to first that's two
lines one to center field and grisham
comes in to make the catch on the
sinking liner
so moscow gets out of the inning
unscathed and the braves will send a
bunch of them at san diego today it's a
opener for jesse chavez yeah three and
two on the air two starts 28 games this
will be his 29th game third start
my ball to lift her right center field
this will be peterson and solaire and
jack peterson the center fielder comes
away with it
that ball is scalded toward left center
peterson on the run can't get there
that'll bounce over the wall for a
double
little chopper that'll get the runner to
third
and machado's retired two outs
two one pitch lobbed out towards ozzy
and shallow right he's positioned
perfectly makes the catch and then sound
number three
and he's taking great advantage of that
as rosario swings and misses strike
three first strike out of the day
here's the one-two pitch darno swings
and misses strike three back-to-back
case for muskrat who's trying to make
that difficult
two down for jack peterson
swing and a drive deep right field jack
peterson has put the braves in front
shocked over and snit knows how to read
a lineup card and put it together
doesn't it yeah perfect time for that
match up a two-out home run from
peterson and the braves strike first
strike three call and that'll end the
inning an old 49 hitter over the course
of his long career swings of the first
pitch grounds a sharply to first base
right to cronenworth he's got it and
brings it himself one pitch one out for
joe here in the third inning so smiley
now uh three for 62.
strike three call jorge scholaire down
by way of the k-4 strikeout for musgrove
two down
there he goes
and a swing and a miss
foul tipped into the catcher's mitt for
strike three
[Applause]
of the year to center field coming in
now going out as jack peterson makes the
catch one down
3-1 pitch lined in the center field
joe moscrow we know he can swing the bat
[Applause]
and it's to right field solaire going
back turns around and that ball's off
the bottom of the wall
musgrove would be stopped at third into
second with a double his second of the
day is jake cronenworth so an
intentional pass to manny with first
base open that'll load them up for jerks
and profar who as we talk
[Applause]
high in the air on the first pitch
rosario is underneath and smiley escapes
the third inning
[Applause]
smoke that breaking ball down the line
and kept it fair
right at the 3 42 sign austin riley
golfs a leadoff double it's a 12-game
hitting streak
and he gets one able to pick up his
sixth k of the day second time rosario's
down by way of the k
one out here in the fourth inning riley
at second base and travis
darnell darnold runner at second one out
he scalds that ball deep toward right
center field grisham going back that
ball is off the base of the wall
strolling home is riley darno hammers
the ball to right center braves extend
the lead it's two to nothing second walk
allowed by muscaro but now they bat in
the hands of ada adrianza 2-0 pitch on
the way hit in the air towards center
field trent grisham coming in now coming
in with urgency he misplayed it that's
in front of him and drops to the ground
that'll score darno dansby goes first to
third
and the braves are more than happy to
cash in on him 2-2
swinging a miss and solaire strikes out
sharply hit and caught by dansby
[Applause]
they majorly pop up
shallow right ozzy backpedals and very
shallow right he's got a two down
[Music]
wow that was impressive
devastating change up
fly ball down the first baseline and
into foul ground for cronenworth who
leans into the screen and makes the
catch
oh that's the crown zone two
wherever jake is is where the crown zone
is got overturned as a challenging it
was the braves that grabbed some screen
apparently and it did so it is a foul
ball
oh two swinging to miss all works out
for joe
fly ball shallow right out goes alby
solaire coming in and it's going to fall
throw go to second and safe there is
myers had to wade halfway
so two on and nobody out for cronenworth
tying around at the plate just like that
for the padres
line down the right field line fair ball
headed towards the corner myers coming
around to score frazier's going to try
and score
he will it is a two-run triple for jake
cronenworth and the padres are back
within a run infield in with the tying
run 90 feet away manny at the plate
and a ground ball right up in the middle
into center field for a base hit machado
has tied the game chronoworth comes in
from third and it's three to three in
the fifth and it will be arcea for aj
minter
scalded to right and fair headed for the
corner around second peterson he's on
his way to third wash is gonna wave him
here comes jock they miss the cutoff man
and the braves are back in front
[Applause]
with two down
he struck him out
kim
tagged out and that's your inning
ozzy
high fly ball left center field look at
that ball carry it's off the base of the
wall
alby's on his way to second he just
missed hitting a home run and the braves
have an insurance run aboard with one
out
line and caught a third by machado
trying to make it two but albies gets
back to the bag and here you go two on
nobody out in the bottom of the ninth
inning and the pinch hitter will be
fernando tati's junior
truck came out one down
tying run is now 90 feet away and the
winning run is in scoring position well
trent won't be able to walk it off with
a wild pitch but he does have an
opportunity to win this ball game here
[Applause]
come out looking two down bases loaded
ha sung kim
struck him out struck him out braves win
braves win 4-3
[Applause]